-Our first guest is an Emmy,
Grammy, and Tony winner
who wrote eight original songs
for the movie "Encanto,"
which is streaming now
on Disney+
and whose soundtrack is
the number one soundtrack
on the Billboard charts.
Ladies and gentlemen, please
welcome Lin-Manuel Miranda.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
That's what I'm talking about!
That's what I'm talking about,
you feel the love, right?
Do you hear that? Come on.
-Hi, everybody.
-Come on.
-Love you.
-It is great to see you.
I love that.
I love the short cut,
the short haircut.
-Thank you. Yeah. I left my hair
in four movies back in 2020.
-You really did. Yeah.
I want to talk about a little
bit, if we can --
Tick, Tick, Boom.
That was the last time you were
on our show
right before that release.
Were you happy
with the response?
I mean, it's been nominated
for all these awards.
-I'm so thrilled.
It's it's just been amazing.
The response to my artists
who are at a crossroads
in their lives
and see the movie,
and that's exactly
what it speaks to.
And then what I didn't
anticipate was folks
who aren't artists
who kind of understand it.
Like I've, I've heard
from a lot of young writers
who showed the movie
to their families to,
like, make them understand
what they go through.
I remember screening a rough cut
of the movie from my in-laws
and my father in-law,
who is not in the arts at all,
there's a scene in the movie
where, you know,
the agent tells Jonathan
Jonathan's work falls through
and he goes,
"What am I supposed to do now?"
And she says,
"You write the next one
and then you write the next one
and then you do that again."
And that's what it is
to be a writer.
And I remember my father in-law
like looking at me
as if he saw me for the first
time and went, "Jesus Christ.
Is that your life?"
-Yeah.
Is that right?
And congrats, by the way,
if you just got nominated
for Best Director by the DGA.
So that's.
First jet, first jam out!
Come on, buddy.
It's streaming now on Netflix
if you want to see.
Just, it's just a great movie,
great performances all around.
-And Andrew Garfield,
he's very good.
Andrew Garfield is just an
insane --
did he, by the way,
did Andrew Garfield,
did he tell you about
"Spider-Man" at all?
When you worked with him?
-He didn't.
But can I tell the story?
So the day it leaked,
he might be involved.
He was on my set.
We were still filming.
And between shots,
I kind of quietly went over
to him and was like,
"Are you in the new
'Spider-Man'?"
And he exact reaction was,
"What? Shut up, shut up.
Ha ha ha, shut up."
And I walked away thinking, "Oh,
he's in the new 'Spider-Man.'"
And then when I saw him
on your show,
like, he was a total
pro at denying it.
-Oh yeah.
-But he had to get there.
-Yeah, he had to get there,
that's right.
Let's talk about "Encanto"
right now.
Congrats on all this.
It's streaming now on Disney+.
You wrote eight
original songs for it,
and the soundtrack is number one
on the Billboard charts.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Bumped Adele out of
the number one spot, by the way.
-I didn't my heart.
-Not it's not in your heart.
Me neither. Not my heart, yeah.
Of course love, Adele.
We don't talk about Bruno
is officially the biggest single
ever from a Disney movie
bigger than "Let It Go."
Did you -- what?
Did you know, did you feel
coming, did you see this coming?
-No. Mainly because
it's like group numbers
never get the same kind
of love like that.
The ballads get or the,
you know, the comedy songs get.
But I didn't know it was catchy
because when I was first
writing it,
I would catch my kids singing it
just from overhearing me
writing it.
And I remember I had had to have
a like NDA
for toddlers conversation
with them.
I was like, "You guys can't
sing this at school."
We can only sing this around
the house
because you know, your friends
don't don't know the song yet.
-So, we don't talk about,
we don't. We don't talk.
-We don't talk about.
We don't talk about Bruno.
-Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
All the songs
I love the beautiful song.
Is it Dos Oruguitas means
two caterpillars?
-Yeah.
-And it's just gorgeous.
But is this the first song
you've written in completely
in Spanish?
Yeah, it was.
It was the first song
that written beginning
to end in Spanish.
The second Colombia, Mi Encanto
is earlier in the movie,
but honestly,
it's the the moment
where that song happens
is this moment of kind of
unspeakable tragedy.
You know, Abuela is telling this
really tough story from her,
from her youth and the notion
of her singing that felt wrong.
So it was like, "Alright, so we
need to have something that --
Sometimes you figure out
what a song
is by figuring out
what it's not.
And I thought, "We need, like,
a nature metaphor."
We need it to feel like
a folk song
that's kind of always existed.
And so then I thought,
"What if it's about
these two caterpillars in love
and they don't want
to let go of each other,
but they have to let
go of each other
so that the miracle can happen
and they can become
their next selves?"
-I mean, it's just
it's describing everyone's
welling up here.
They are through Zoom.
You're the first person to make
someone cry through Zoom.
Oh my gosh.
-Well, you know, it's funny,
and I kind of just
sort of pitch that,
and I wrote the first verse
and chorus
and played it for the rest
of the creative team
at our weekly music
Zoom meetings.
I only had like the first verse
through the chorus,
and I played it for them,
and I just remember
that reaction.
It was just like, "You should
probably keep writing it."
[ Laughter ]
I think we got something there.
Okay.
Yeah, I want to show
everyone a clip.
Here is that song
from Disney's "Encanto."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-♪ Dos oruguitas ♪
♪ Enamoradas ♪
♪ Pasan sus noches ♪
♪ Y madrugadas ♪
♪ Llenas de hambre ♪
♪ Siguen andando ♪
♪ Y navegando un mundo ♪
♪ Que cambia y sigue cambiando ♪
♪ Navegando un mundo ♪
-Lin-Manuel Miranda.
"Encanto" is streaming now
on Disney+
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.